kevin what's going on
hey
how are you
good good to be on the show thanks for
having me
absolutely forward to chatting lightning
let's uh let's start with just give
everyone kind of a quick uh overview of
your background and what you do uh kind
of day-to-day right now just some people
understand your perspective
yeah um so i've been in crypto for three
or four years um have kind of watched
the growth of lightning from the early
days not really
uh
paying too much attention to it early on
but um
around earlier this year i really got
into it and um started doing a lot of
research on it and and that's a lot of
what i do today is uh research and
investing in crypto
and i started to notice in april and may
when this el salvador news came out and
all of a sudden the the lightning
networks were going to have this real
use case
i started to notice the growth of the
network and i started to follow along
with it and really dove down that rabbit
hole and uh
yeah started studying it
got myself set up on a lightning node
started routing payments and started uh
realizing that not only is this like a
much better user experience for moving
money around on the bitcoin network it
is uh it's really misunderstood and so
that was kind of the piece i wrote
earlier this week was about
um
why why we are not really thinking of
lightning in the correct lens we're
looking at it through the the wrong lens
and uh because of that we think it's a
it's a smaller protocol than it actually
is there's a lot more activity happening
on it than people realize
um and this this is really just what
gets me going i think i'm i'm really
excited about uh
how big this network is today and how
big it can be tomorrow yeah i uh i think
i share the excitement and kind of
passion for this as you do um let's
start with just a high level like what
is the lightning network people probably
heard about it they know it's something
to do with bitcoin but they may not
actually understand just at a high level
like what is the lightning network
supposed to be
yeah so super high level protocol for
making
instant and nearly free payments on
bitcoin right and so there are
right now uh well over 10 000 active
nodes running on this like layer two
that's lightning we've got a layer two
technology um
and what is what's really happening is
um people are
on the bitcoin network entering into an
agreement between two
two nodes so let's say you and i uh
decide that we want to uh set up a
channel on the lightning network
we can enter into an agreement on the
bitcoin network we can open up a channel
on this layer two and all of a sudden
you and i can send send funds back and
forth between each other or between
other nodes on the network without
making an on-chain transaction
so um the idea is that anyone can pay
anyone um for basically no cost and uh
you know permissionless and it has all
the same properties as
the base bitcoin blockchain does um just
it's optimized for payments
got it and so you wrote this piece
recently and what you basically did was
you broke down uh how folks evaluate the
lightning network and then where you
felt like that evaluation was fair and
accurate and then where you thought that
it could be a little misleading and so
if we start just maybe with uh this idea
of value locked in the network that's a
term or a concept that became very
popular in the decentralized finance
space usually on the smart contract
platforms but walk us through kind of
where we are from a value locked in the
lightning network and then why you think
that that might not be an accurate kind
of way to measure this specific network
yeah so
right now the way it's often framed is
that the lightning network has this has
people look at like the network capacity
which is the amount of bitcoin uh that
every kind of node has
on the network um they look at that and
they say well this is total value locked
and they compare it instinctively to
uh a lot of the d5 particles so maker
compound ave unit swap they all kind of
use this same tvl total value locked
metric
to measure their growth against each
other
but it's
tvl
uh is uh
it helps
d5 protocols kind of like over estimate
their size
there's a lot of uh incentive like d5
protocols have uh inflation built into
their um often built into their tokens
there's uh yield farming that goes on
that that
incentivizes capital to move on to those
platforms
and that kind of overestimates their
actual demand for tbl people are just
kind of going there for
yield farming or for earning a earning
interest rates on something
but lightning underestimates it
lightning has a few different
um
a few different reasons why tvl is not
actually
value locked in the lightning protocol
the first is that some of the channels
on lightning are private
so uh that's not visible on the network
graph there's no way of seeing um what
what capacity all these channels have
so there's there's always going to be a
uh
the the metric that people use as tvl is
always going to be underestimating the
actual size of the complete lightning
network we just don't know
entirely how big the how much bigger it
is but it is going to be always bigger
because there's private channels um
that aren't advertising their capacity
um
and furthermore it's it's
tvl itself is a metric about like
locking value and putting it
like amassing capital and lightning
isn't really about that lightning is
about making payments
right so this is not
an amm this is not a borrowing protocol
this is not like we're not trying to
collect a bunch of funds on this
protocol we're trying to we're trying to
move funds between people
and payment volume is one of those
metrics that can't be tracked it uh it's
you know lightning is private by design
so
that is actually probably one of the
more important metrics but it gets it
gets overshadowed it gets um
you know there's no way to actually
measure it so people go with the next
best thing which is they look at network
capacity and they call that tvl
which is kind of misleading but that's
um it's the most available metric so
that's what people tend to gravitate to
so it seems like what people are
basically doing is they're trying to use
a couple of different frameworks to
evaluate uh where is lightning network
today what is the total kind of uh
opportunity set at the given moment and
then try to use that as a way to
establish where it's going uh the first
is they're using metrics or frameworks
that have been used in other parts of
the industry and then applying it here
but the difference being this is a
payment system versus those other
systems where actually locking value for
liquidity uh or market making is
important here it is not because it's a
true kind of payment system so that
sounds like one piece of this the second
piece is that
with the data that you can query around
nodes etc uh there's public and private
uh components to it and so people can
only cite the public
they can't get the private data and so
they just run with the public data but
it's actually a bigger number when you
have public and private just we don't
know what that private number is is that
a fair character
characterization of where we are
yeah i think so and then the payment
volume itself is just something that no
one has any real insight into like you
and i can send funds back and forth on
the lightning network we could send 100
transactions a minute back and forth and
uh that that doesn't appear anywhere
there's no lightning explorer that is
going to show
the actual
value of funds being moved across the
lightning network so one example would
be you know strike using lightning as
the kind of the back end
of their app it's it's like they aren't
showing any of their payment volume to
lightning explorers that's that's not
visible so we actually don't know how
much bigger it is than their total
capacity um but chances are they're
moving those funds over quite frequently
in the piece that you wrote you used a a
couple of uh examples specifically
lightning network markets or ln network
or i'm sorry ln markets or bitterroo
and ln markets is a derivatives platform
that's built on top of the lightning
network bitaroo is an australian bitcoin
exchange that offers customers the
ability to deposit and withdraw with the
lightning network and what you
highlighted was uh given that this
information is private we had to wait
for these organizations to basically
publish the information and so uh ellen
market said that they've done 200
million dollars of volume on the
platform since march 2020 and then you
showed that uh bitterroot did 54 million
dollars of payment volume through the
lightning network uh in the last nine
months or so and so your point here was
basically that if 50 to 200 million
dollars is being done with platforms
that are not you know the most popular
uh in the industry or or kind of
well-known uh your estimation is that
the payment volume is somewhere in the
billions to tens of billions of dollars
on an annual basis
yeah i think i mean
you if you see uh bitaru and ln markets
doing 50 to 200 million dollars in
annual volume um
bitaru is the like 800th largest node on
the network uh there are a lot of uh
apps and other nodes that are doing far
more volume um
you you know bitfinex has uh two nodes
and a total combined capacity of 300
bitcoin
on their two on their two nodes and so
you start to think like bitfinex is one
of the you know largest crypto exchanges
out there it's got 300 bitcoin that
they've decided to put on lightning
they're not doing that for fun you know
they're doing that to move funds back
and forth and do they've enabled
withdrawals and deposits um through
lightning and so
you know the the network is far larger
when you take a look at payment volume
versus node capacity because you can
move payments back and forth so quickly
and it's so cheap there's there's no
cost really to making these payments
they're they're far i mean they're like
a fraction of a penny sometimes if you
have to if you have to route a payment
if you make a direct payment it's free
and so when you lower the barriers to
making these payments all of a sudden
payment velocity can go up so i think i
think the actual payment figure is
higher than a lot of people
realize or think it is um
but
you know as you said we we don't have a
complete picture of how big payment
volume is because not all this
information is being published so we
kind of have to rely on clues from
from companies that choose to publish it
themselves
and then alex bosworth is a lightning
infrastructure uh engineer lightning
labs he leads that uh that part of their
work um and in your psu highlighted some
of his recent comments around how much
money he's making uh from actually
routing transactions so uh before we
talk about maybe the the math around
what he's doing just help people
understand right people always ask like
how do i participate in the lightning
network is there a way that i could um
uh mine or route transactions or buy
things like like what's the financial
opportunity and i think that routing
transactions ends up being where many
people settle so like how does that work
and then how do people get paid for
doing it
yeah so the easiest way and this is
in the last month or so i set up a node
using something called umbral
and uh i think it's get umbrella.org or
dot com
and uh that's probably the easiest
solution out there for a lot of people
it's 100 or 200 bucks you get
six or seven computer parts you get a
little raspberry pi and there's
instructions on how to um you know
connect all the parts and
sync to the you you run a bitcoin node
and a lightning node and umbrell has
their software and that kind of
interfaces with your with your computer
that you just built um so for 100 or 200
bucks you can get a lightning node um
then you have a wallet and all of a
sudden you can move funds from the
bitcoin uh base chain to lightning and
you can start routing payments right
away so one of the things that i saw
once i started to
move funds onto lightning
is that i woke up one morning and there
was just and funds had moved across i
had put a certain amount of funds in one
channel
and i had a had an amount of inbound
liquidity and outbound liquidity that
proportion changed as funds
moved across the network and so it
happens right away if you're a routing
node
you can you can set fees on how much how
much you want to earn for passing a
payment through
um and so that this is kind of getting
to alex bosworth's node he's a routing
node and he's earning when the payments
a payment comes in through one of his
channels and goes out to another one of
his channels and it's it we don't know
which party is sending the payment and
which party is receiving the payment all
we know is that it's using his channels
and the liquidity in those channels to
get the payment across the network so
he's he's earning a fee for that um his
fee is about 25 basis points
which is probably on the higher end but
he's a very well connected node it's got
a lot of capital in there i think
roughly
25 30 bitcoin of capital um
in his
channels
on his two different notes
um and so he's earning quite a bit of
money from routing those payments
because he's well connected so if i'm
trying to send a transaction to someone
i've never met before
i may not be connected to that person i
may be using alex's node um because he
has a connection to someone else who has
a connection to someone else who has a
connection to that person
and uh
yeah that's that's kind of the the
basics of routing and you can genuinely
make money uh but it is a it's a
competitive market in the same way that
bitcoin mining is a competitive market
it's permissionless anyone can do it
anyone can join and so naturally that
means like everyone's trying to undercut
each other everyone with bitcoin mining
everyone's trying to find cheaper energy
on lightning everyone's trying to find
better uh channels to open and better
nodes to connect to and better
paths to route through so it's it's
always gonna be this really competitive
market
i imagine margins are gonna be pretty
slim
but uh you you absolutely can earn money
uh routing on lightning
yeah it's absolutely fascinating i think
that um you know when you take all of
this into uh consideration it's very
obvious that this is headed in the right
direction one of the reasons why i've
been so bullish in the lighting network
uh both just in terms of conceptually
what they're trying to accomplish but
also uh with investments in strike and
other types of businesses like that is
it feels like lightning is taking the
organic growth path it doesn't have uh
some sort of airdrop mechanism or yield
farming or something that can kind of
short-circuit the growth and so what it
does is it will have much more steady
growth kind of in the beginning uh and
kind of slower growth but those people
end up being really really sticky high
retention users of the product right
they stay on the network they don't
leave they don't jump to the next
network that shows up just with you know
better uh returns on some sort of
airdrop or farming or whatever and so
when you start to look at growth in
general
what
initially kind of pulled me to the piece
that you wrote was uh the growth
has been kind of what i'd consider slow
and steady so so a positive uh organic
growth exactly what you would want to
see but it's starting to pick up now and
so you highlighted a couple of different
numbers in april may june and into july
that just shows like
we may be hitting a little bit of an
inflection point here kind of walk us
through you know what those statistics
are and how you think about this growth
and and kind of what it means for
lightning in general
yeah absolutely so that's that's one of
the things that also drew me in in the
last few months has been watching these
numbers grow
not only not only grow not only grow
from in an absolute way like the network
capacity is
month to month the number of bitcoin
being added in network capacity grows
but also in a percentage so from a
higher base all every month the
uh percentage of bit of bitcoin added to
total uh lightning
um network capacity is growing so as an
example i put in the piece
during april uh in the beginning of
april there was 1169 bitcoin a public
network capacity online
at the end of the month there was uh
1231. and so there was that was a five
percent growth in the month of april the
month of may went from 1231 to about
1400 that was a 14 growth
uh from a higher base
then the month of june went from 1400 to
1650 bitcoin uh and that again is it's
bigger growth it was 18 growth from
another higher base and in july was 1650
up to 2100 bitcoin uh and now we're
pushing 2200 bitcoin locked on the
network
um and uh you know that is 27
in in that last month um and so
you know it's not only growing it's not
only growing from an absolute basis but
it's growing as a percentage which is
really really rare
and um
it doesn't take much imagination to see
how quickly this can continue to grow if
you know if the next month it grows by
30 40 50
it's not long before you've got 10 000
bitcoin 15 000 bitcoin 20 000 bitcoin
unleashed on the lightning network
you mentioned
el salvador twitter square etc i think
that uh definitely the bitcoin community
uh you know i've been saying for a while
twitter square should merge embrace
bitcoin game over you know one of the
most powerful companies in the world
were the most uh important valuable
companies in the world i don't think
we're there yet but uh
what is the relationship between
companies like a twitter or a square or
a country like el salvador and the
lightning network
well when i look at that i i just think
it's the
it's
there there are two or three catalysts
that have the potential to onboard
millions or tens of millions or hundreds
of millions of users right and that
would be so el salvador is probably the
the short-term catalyst where i think
it's september 7th their bitcoin bill
goes into effect and um every citizen is
going to be airdropped drop 30 of
bitcoin on lightning every merchant will
will uh be required to accept it as
payment all of a sudden you have
everyone with everyone in el salvador
has a lightning wallet everyone in el
salvador has bitcoin um their relatives
who are sending money through remittance
channels twenty four percent of el
salvador's gdp's remittances um
they can now send uh money through
lightning and now all of a sudden
they're on board too so you know you can
quickly see how the six million people
in el salvador
can branch out into this like larger
network that is sending and receiving
funds um and you know six million can
turn into 10 12 million when you when
you take into account the relatives of
people in el salvador then all of a
sudden a neighboring country decides to
do the same there's like really really
compelling network effects that are
being built right now um and i think
that's the short-term catalyst to watch
out for
is how quickly is el salvador going to
kind of adopt this and and how important
is lightning going to be in their
day-to-day lives we've seen some good
examples already with bitcoin beach
um but it'll be really interesting to
see in september what happens um across
the country once everyone is on
lightning um and i think the same
you know twitter twitter actually
i think is a a really
i don't know if you remember this but
there was a there was a product called
tippin on twitter uh i guess a couple
years ago it had a it had a moment and
um
it basically enabled anyone to send
uh lightning payments to twitter account
and i thought that was like a great
integration it was someone it was
someone unrelated to twitter that built
it but it enabled anyone to move money
to directly to a twitter account and i
remember getting a few stats from from
some people online and i was just like
that's really cool but i don't know what
to do with it and so
that was kind of like a
first aha moment i had a little bit of
an aha moment i was like i can i can
receive money
through my twitter account it's just
like i just think this is like the most
obvious next step for twitter to make
this a native integration um make it
possible to like withdraw funds and move
them uh to different wallets and i think
that's like another you know twitter's
got 206 million daily active users i
think
that is an enormous uh
pool of people that you can pull from if
you enable some tip jar feature with
lightning or
super follow instead of paying five
dollars a month through paypal and
getting charged
you know 40 cents for a transaction um
all of a sudden you can you can tip
someone you can tip someone 40 cents you
can have someone four cents you know you
there's no limit to how small these
payments can be
and i think that really opens up a lot
of possibilities and yeah i hope i hope
twitter and square both kind of uh
release some uh lightning integrations
in the near future
what are you most excited about
is it individual users is it companies
nation states the the totality of
everyone using it like when you think of
lightning what gets you the most excited
i think i don't think it's any of those
things i think the thing that gets me
the most excited is that
this is a
it's a like a radical decrease in the
cost of making a transaction it's like
we don't have any platform in the world
where you can make a permissionless uh
transfer to or from anyone
for
basically free and instantly you know we
have we have some silos we have you know
cash up if you're a us user maybe you
can make a free transaction but you're
trusting square you're trusting some of
the banking system um you can't use it
internationally
like i can't use it in canada there's
you know paypal is going to charge you a
fee there may be a time delay there's
lightning is the first implementation of
this
idea that you can move value to or from
anyone
instantly and for free
um and it can scale to the world
which is i i think it's really
incredible and i i start to think about
you know past innovations past like
networks and
even just
radical cost declines in certain
technologies um i think back to like
the early uh 1900s in america when when
homes all across the country were being
um outfitted with with
a few different networks so one was
electricity um sewage
water all these like all these systems
that radically decrease the cost of
um
getting fresh water uh you know turning
on a light
makes it it makes it instant right as
soon as you have thomas edison set up
his pearl street station
people all of a sudden have free and
instant access to light
as soon as you have an air conditioner
come on you have free and instant access
to manipulate temperature
these things have really really wide
ranging impacts i was actually studying
the
kind of history of the air conditioner
and
um
some of the like wide-ranging impacts or
like it
people live longer when they have air
conditioning it caused a mass migration
in the u.s towards the south uh half of
the country in the
latter half of the 20th century
and um
hollywood's golden age coincided with
the time that air conditioners started
to be put into movie theaters there's
like really dramatic wide-ranging
effects for
what you otherwise would think is just
like you know oh i can make the room
cooler
it changes refrigeration you can now
move food across the country across the
world you can access foods that you
never could before it changes so many
things when you can when you can
decrease the cost and make it instant
you can instantly access a colder
temperature if you want um
it and lightning is the same way like
you can instantly send money in any
denomination you want um and so i think
there's a lot of these low value kind of
transactions that have never been able
to be spent um things like
play to earn games like there's there's
a thunder games is a app that uh or it's
a studio they build a couple of uh
bitcoin games you can earn sats for
playing a video game every day they give
out stats to thousands of people
um in small small denominations that
wouldn't be possible on chain
um streaming podcasts you can
tip creators for
uh you know every minute of a podcast
that you listen to people come in tune
into the show and watch five minutes of
it they can tip you for the exact amount
of time that they're watching
um messaging platforms you can all of a
sudden build groups where people have to
pay to send a message all of a sudden
you reduce a lot of spam you you open up
some new possibilities for what these
platforms could be
um and so i think there's a lot to
uh
yeah there's there's a lot of
possibilities we don't know what the
second order effects are going to be of
lightning but i i know that when
in the past when we have seen
innovations that radically decrease the
cost
and make make something instant
you know faster cheaper
anything like that is often come with uh
really wide ranging effects and so i
think that's going to be the same for
lightning john what questions do you
have
yeah kevin thank you for doing this i
really appreciate you sharing your
knowledge with everyone um i kind of
have a two-part question so first like
what are the disadvantages if any to the
lightning network like why would someone
not want to use it and then also like
what's gonna drive further adoption of
the lightning network for people to use
it um and so on
so i think the the disadvantage right
now is it is not easy to use it is you
know even even setting up a note on
umbral which i think was a relatively
easy experience
you have to buy hardware you have to you
know i get a shipment from amazon i have
to build this little computer uh set up
a node takes a few days to sync
is a there's a bit of a learning curve
and uh
i'm not i'm not
fully up to speed on like all the
technology risks and security risks um
but i think it's
initially like that that's what kept me
from the lightning network for the last
couple years and it was only about a
month ago that i that i set up my own
node was that it just seemed like it was
a very
um difficult
network to be a part of i didn't really
know why i should be a part of it as you
start to see more apps though pop up so
like you have users you have capital you
have um now countries that are kind of
using lightning to settle payments
all of a sudden this opens the doors for
developers to come in and say i'm going
to build an incredible app on lightning
because there's 10 million people in el
salvador and they're relatives and
there's people on twitter that are using
this and now there's an addressable
market and so
i think that's kind of going to be a
catalyst for growth it's a flywheel
right like you you have users and
capital that start to accumulate on the
network attracts developers these
developers attract more users more
capital so
um it's it's organic um and you know
this is something we chat about earlier
is this is like an organic demand
driving and uh
it's yeah i think i think that flywheel
is really starting to turn and um
i've started to see a lot more lightning
startups being built and
um the ecosystem's flourishing i think
definitely
what do you what's your favorite uh
application right now or uh or kind of
um you know software interface to light
networks anything that you use on a
daily or weekly basis
uh i started using ln markets a lot
um that's a bitcoin derivatives platform
i truly think it is the fastest
trading platform in the entire crypto
industry
there's no no kyc no verification you
can send funds directly from your node
they arrive instantly
you can open a position in a single
click uh you can you close a position in
a single click you can withdraw funds in
a single in a second
um it's just like an incredibly fast
experience and
it just makes me cringe to think about
how much time i had wasted in previous
years you know going through
kyc process verification waiting a few
days uh figuring out how to send funds
from a bank to you know buy some bitcoin
uh
they make it really seamless you got to
get on lightning to use it but once
you're on there it's really it's a
magical kind of experience
where can we send people to learn more
about lightning is there uh i know
you've written a couple of pieces uh on
your blog should we send people there
are there other resources that you
usually suggest to folks
yeah so one
this one's a little more technical um
but the first few chapters are pretty
good for anyone trying to learn more
about it uh there's a book called
mastering the lightning network and it's
available on github right now i don't
think the uh hardcover kind of final
polish book has been released yet but
you can you can read a lot of it on
github for free
and that is written by
andreas antonopoulos
i think
i think someone at lightning labs is
also a co-author and um
i can't remember there's three there's
three uh authors um but that's those
those are like the ogs of light like
they really truly understand the
protocol and uh there's a lot of like
foundational knowledge to learn there
um if you want to learn more about like
the ecosystem and all the apps being
built on it uh jameson lot has some
really good resources on his site i
think it's lop.net and
forward slash lightning information
uh
great stuff there's like 40 or 50 apps
that i had never heard of that are
already
in action and you can you can use them
to either earn sats or send sets
um so that's really good resource to
start with
love it uh and then where uh where can
people follow you on twitter
yeah i'm at ke rook on twitter and uh i
write a lot of long form research on
kevinrook.blog
yeah
i i think you're doing a fantastic job
and i always enjoy finding uh kind of
the corners of the internet where it's
like oh wait a minute there's like a
whole i could read about this all day
long this is uh pretty high quality so i
appreciate you uh
jumping on here and kind of explain it
to everyone as i was saying to folks in
the comments uh i think lightning is
probably one of the most uh
misunderstood and uh mispriced
opportunities right now and so uh
obviously in things like strike uh there
will be opportunities to invest in
companies but also just the usage of it
the adoption uh and kind of what it'll
do for bitcoin and the network on a
global basis is uh pretty powerful as
you've outlined so i appreciate you
taking the time to do it
yeah of course and i think one other
thing is i think there's an additional
um
a couple more additional like effects
because lightning is built on bitcoin um
this is the only way to access it
directly is to buy bitcoin i think
that's another kind of advantage it has
over some of the um
you know when you think about like
how uh
it's positioned um compared to like d5
protocols and stuff like that where um
if you're investing in that in the d5
space you don't know should you buy a
compound ave should you buy ether should
you buy there's like a bunch of
different tokens you can purchase
lightning to kind of uh
if you're investing in that if you're
kind of uh
betting on the network's success the
only way to do it is through bitcoin
directly um and so i think that's
another kind of compelling advantage it
has it's very focused on
you know this this resilient network
that has already proven itself
and um
yeah there's no there's no distractions
associated with it
uh yeah i tend to think that you are
more right than wrong and you're onto
something so keep banging the drum that
is uh that is what we need so appreciate
you taking time to jump on and we'll
definitely do together in the future
sounds good thanks for having me on hey
guys thanks so much for watching that
clip of the best business show make sure
you like and subscribe to the channel
turn on notifications so you know when
we go live every weekday and then head
to sofi.com so that you can get an
account we can get after it
you